il a été embauché en novembre dernier
pour travailler dans cette structure
france service en plus de l'accueil elle
se doit d'être polyvalente pour répondre
à toutes les demandes
on a suivi une formation sur trois jours
on a rencontré tous les partenaires et
nous on
présenté leur site et comment faire les
premières démarches auprès de ses
partenaires donc créé les comptes faire
des demandes d'allocations et voilà pour
chaque partenaire
on retrouve la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie pôle emploi la caf
ou encore la poste
regroupés en un seul guichet unique
l'objectif c'est véritablement de
délivrer un service de proximité
sachant qu'il ya bien sûr d'autres
services et d'autres moyens de
communication avec la caisse
d'allocations familiales puisqu'une nous
leur offrons également la possibilité de
prendre contact avec nous via
effectivement internet le numérique
justement internet permet d'aller vite
mais cela peut exclure d'autres
personnes moins à l'aise avec les
nouvelles technologies
ces structures sont une nouvelle manière
de concevoir les différents services
publics est effectivement des
particuliers qui n'ont pas accès au
numérique facilement donc danser france
service il y aura aussi un développement
de services d'accompagnement aux
démarches numérique
on cherche à are en bleu cible nos
concitoyens autonome deux sont
inaugurées dans le cher aubigny sur nère
et sancoins en 2020 21 structures
recevront ce label france services en
région centre val de loire